I recently read your piece on how does glutamate feed cancer.
It had a couple of questions.
Number one, my doctor recently put me on sodium fetal muterate
as a metabolic blockade of glutamine.
Does this accomplish the same thing as glutamate scavenger 2?
So the easy answer that is no.
It doesn't do the same thing as glutamate scavenger 2.
Glutamate scavenger 2 helps get rid of glutamate.
So understand, there's a difference between glutamine and glutamate.
Glutamine converts to glutamate and glutamate to glutamine in the body.
But there are two different things.
Glutamate is not a feeder of cancer.
Glutamine is a fuel source of cancer.
It can be a fuel source of cancer.
Glutamate is a neurotransmitter that is a derivative of glutamine.
So I know it gets a little confusing, but there are two different molecular structures.
Now there is a gene called your dad genes that converts this that controls the conversion of glutamine to glutamate.
So buterates in your gut will help with the overall absorption of glutamine, which is good.
So taking both of these things would be the right thing to do.
Well, let's go to the second question here.
The bottle does not indicate the timing is the glutamate scavenger best taken with animal proteins at bedtime to support the cleanup process during sleep or some other time.
So glutamate scavenger does not work in the gut.
So it's not blocking absorption of the amino acid glutamine.
It's helping get rid of glutamates in the tissues and in the brain.
So taking it during the day, you know, spreading it out during the day, anytime during the day with meals or without meals, it doesn't make any difference.
Because you're trying to get rid of glutamates.
Now, why would you get rid of glutamates if, you know, I don't have problems with glutamates.
And what would be the evidence of somebody having a problem with glutamates?
Well, glutamates can convert back to glutamine.
So as a person with cancer that has none of the symptoms you're going to talk about in a second here, can still convert glutamate to glutamine and can glutamates can be a fuel source of cancer.
However, a person can have issues with glutamates and not have issues with glutamine, meaning they don't have cancer.
They're taking glutamine further, got, they don't have an issue, quote, unquote, with glutamine.
But a person with a lot of bad defects that gene can convert glutamine to glutamate quite quickly.
And there's a lot of people in that camp and glutamate access is a huge problem in the world.
Because of a few reasons, but glutamate excess could cause a lot of emotional imbalance.
So glutamate is a neurotransmitter, like I said, but it's an excitatory neurotransmitter.
So it up regulates the brain.
Now it's a necessary neurotransmitter.
It's the neurotransmitter that helps you wake up in the morning and get you going.
It's a neurotransmitter that gives you drive and helps you think and process information.
But excess glutamate can cause, you know, excess drive and OCD type symptoms in anxiety type symptoms.
And, and that is a big problem in our society.
So excess glutamate is not good.
So excess glutamate in different forms can even be worse and cause brain inflammation.
It can be a cause of damage to migroglio cells in the brain as well.
That's why you want to really be careful of food consumption that has stimulatory glutamates in it.
Namely MSG.
So MSG, the reason why they put monosodium glutamate in foods is because it makes the food taste better.
Well, let's reframe that.
It really doesn't make the food taste better.
It makes you think the food taste better.
That's, that's exactly what it does.
Because it stimulates glutamate receptors on your tongue which fire glutamate receptors in your brain.
Exciting your brain making you think, wow, these Doritos are so good.
Oh my gosh, these are so delicious.
Give me another one.
They sell more Doritos that way.
Stimulated your brain to make you think that the food is delicious because it's exciting your brain.
Well, you continue to overexcite your brain with excess amount of glutamates consumed.
You can burn neurons and that is one leading cause of early dementia.
So having excess glutamates, not good for microglial driving, not good good for early dementia issues.
It's something you really want to be careful with with cancer because excess glutamates can also convert back to glutamate.
So long story is glutamate and glutamate are different, but they're interchangeable because they can convert back and forth.
The different products that will decrease glutamates can be beneficial for cancer patients.
Because it can decrease the amount of glutamate, but there's other things that can help decrease the absorption of glutamate glutamate and certainly dietary restriction excess glutamate is is a smart thing to do.
Would mutate and scavenger in any way compete with each other. No, totally different things.
They're both to be beneficial.
I also saw glutamate scavenger three. No, you tested for glutamate scavenger two.